[Music]
okay everybody I'm so excited today
because I am joined by Kelly Rowland who
stars in fantasy football which is on
Paramount plus Friday Kelly how you
doing today I'm so good how about you
I'm doing great it's just lovely to talk
to you today I was very excited about
this and what I thought was so
interesting was that you've performed in
a Super Bowl and now you're doing a
football film so if you played football
in real life what position would you
want to play
um I'll say quarterback or running back
okay okay the leader of the squad I like
that now also Kelly uh having been born
in Atlanta was this film extra special
to you
absolutely
um one I mean because I got to be in
Atlanta and see my family while I was
there and
um too I mean the Falcons have a lot of
spirit in the a you know it's a whole
bunch of spirit in the A and it was so
awesome to watch people
um the extras come to set and they had
all their gear on they were ready they
had beautiful energy
um it was also a time where like I I
remember uh Marseille hit me she's like
we need some more extras I was like well
let's just have people call let's like
you know put it on our uh Instagram and
she's like are you sure I was like yes
listen to it so we did it and it was a
ton of people that came oh man so
awesome
um so Atlanta has beautiful spirit
beautiful beautiful spirit
um it's what I love the most about it
um and uh we had a good time for sure
yeah I love that and that that energy
and Good Vibes translates totally into
the so much I really loved and a big
part of this film too is also besides
football is video games you have Madden
in this does Kelly Rowland ever partake
in gaming or have you in the past you
gamer at all
no
um okay
how about phone games huh what about
phone games
no I'm honestly I wish there was a game
I was into right now but um
literally don't have time I wish there
was a game I keep seeing people like
have like these jewels and stuff on
their phones and cars and all kinds of
stuff I'm like well what is that they're
like it's a game kill you don't you
don't play this game I'm like oh
no I love the honesty I hope one day you
get into it now also this may sound
super corny but I do still listen to the
song Survivor every day literally like
today before this interview so what does
that feel like for you to have made art
that like lives on and affects people so
deeply even just today oh it makes me
feel like
yeah
I I did my job
I I did I did my job if if somebody
connects to it they felt seen they felt
heard
um it helped them through their own
personal journey I did my job for sure
yeah love that answer and last question
before I let you go just want to tell
you I love the Michelle Phifer Catwoman
costume on Halloween amazing was that
your personal favorite you ever done
um it was one of my personal faves
here's what I will say if you want to
take on a different kind of something
during Halloween buy you a Catwoman
costume I don't know what happened I was
extra
feline-ish that night I don't know what
what it was I kept like rounds I don't
know what it was but I was just pouncing
and like feisty I don't know what it was
but I had a lot of fun oh man I love
that Total Transformation amazing you
killed it everybody watched Kelly crush
it in fantasy football and Paramount
plus this Friday thank you so much
coming for joining me I hope to talk to
you in the future
thank you thank you